how long has the film actually been done
and has anything changed in the film as
a result of disney
purchasing fox i guess i'm the only one
who can speak to that one
it was strange because most movies have
a chance to go do pickups
or do reshoots it's sort of like
standard for studios but because uh
the merger happened everything sort of
shut down
and so we were probably like 90 done but
the visual effects weren't done
went back into editorial before i went
to go shoot the stand and uh
finish the cut locked it and then uh
just they finished the visual effects
i'd say it changed a little bit because
i hadn't seen it in a year and
uh we just did little things here and
there that we thought of especially
knowing that we couldn't do any pickups
we were happy with how it turned out the
studio kind of gave us creative rain to
go finish it properly uh
and nobody bothered us so that i
couldn't have asked for more
that yeah i can only that i'm sure every
filmmaker wishes they had that
well to to do a double double-edged
blade
for the cast and and for you josh um
this is one of those films that's had a
few release dates
and something always seems to come up
have you guys actually tried picking up
the phone
and calling people and said look there's
this thing called disney plus
they have hulu do we want to say effort
and
you know you sign contracts that sort of
guarantee a theatrical release so it
needs to open to ever go digital in the
first
place but uh we just too would like
people to see it in the theater but uh
it needs to obviously be at the right
time when it's safe to go back have any
of you called anyone and said hey you
know there
there's this thing called disney plus
uh i speak regularly to the guys at
disney and
i'm i'm told that this is the plan is to
go theatrical
so we're i'm happy with that no no
totally i'm just messing with you guys
one of the things that's cool about this
panel that you guys just did for
comic-con as you showed the first three
and a half minutes of the movie
um for the cast was have you guys seen
the finished film was this your first
time seeing the footage
yeah yeah but we saw the film i'm so
glad that we saw it we saw it before
right before everything started
right yeah yeah yeah yeah so back in
march beginning of march was it
yeah yeah we got to we were doing some
press in on
new york and we got screening in new
york and we got to see it and
yeah i mean i speak can speak for myself
but i think it was kind of a mutual
feeling with the cast but
you know from the initial filming
process and then the initial release
you know there was there was also a lot
of time during that merger where
like you were saying the cast didn't
know what was going on
you know we hadn't seen what was going
on i mean yeah
we didn't we didn't get to see anything
and you know during that time you are
constantly wondering what's going on and
it can be phone calls but
what ended up for me what was really
nice there was you know i mean
unintentionally there was this
big separation from from the movie so
yeah eventually the curiosity when i
when we got to see it
back in march like this yeah it was like
such a pleasant
like uh and i don't want to say pleasant
surprise but just
such a pleasant feeling to step away
from something for so long
and then to come back and to be like oh
wow yeah oh
you know and have that experience almost
as a viewer
so yeah we might get to see the bear
and lockheed and all that because uh you
know that that was the stuff that they
really
was never done until just this past year
yeah
to piggyback on charlie's uh pleasant
surprise
comment i also thought you know we were
going to feel a lot of the horror
elements
come through and to my surprise the
movie has so much
heart it has such a beautiful story that
was like whoa maybe this is
a romance with tones of horror in it and
it was just it just took me by surprise
in such a such a good way
was it well i think i am uh to
inevitably uh d
i do make the things i make do tend to
be uh
the emotional and character driven so
that sort of is what it is
uh regardless of the genre i guess but
yeah we were in
the actors that i had were such great uh
interested in character and character
actors so it's like uh it became more
interesting than just a
superhero movie i guess i think the
reason the comic book movie if you will
the genre
has been so successful is that each of
the films has
pushed the boundaries of what the genre
can do and i'm curious how does new
mutants
maybe do things differently or show
things differently or
you know what i mean um as compared to
other comic book movies that have come
before
i mean for me just aesthetically and
tonally and uh
the way we went about shooting it uh
is much more in line with like uh it's
all real locations and real it's just uh
very different from like a a larger
scale marvel movie i mean to me it
really feels like a throwback movie to
like a 90s horror movie
it becomes a superhero movie in the last
act i guess
yeah i'd like to just yeah add on to
that i think
how contained it is you know we're such
a small cast
so you know you don't it's i mean not
always but it's a lot of the time
you know superhero versus evil save
humanity and really
in our story it's this contain kind of
uh mutants dealing with inner trauma
just as much as like kind of outer uh
um kind of enemy i guess
but in a sense so that that's different
i think it kind of zones in
a little more it is a superhero movie
you know obviously
but um it's definitely more than that it
felt like
um i'm not making like an indie i don't
even know what that means
anymore but um you know making something
really contains and something small it's
about the characters and the romance and
it's very emotional um yeah it's a
really
it's a really pretty movie i think and i
i definitely agree with what henry said
about it really being
um a romance at the core of it a love
story
and um you know a love story between
friends too
yeah absolutely yeah friendship story
friendship story with some kissing
story with some hot sexiness
you know something though ultimately we
all go to the movies and the reason we
all care about
characters is when you get to see
characters talking it's not all about
the big action set pieces
if you don't care about the people that
you're watching really makes no
difference
if there's a huge action scene exactly
it doesn't it doesn't hide behind the
action scenes you get to peel
the onion of all the characters before
they get to
be exposed to their own powers because
that's their biggest fear so that's
i think what josh and the whole cast
achieved really well
was to really peel those layers before
you get you know the gimmicks of
these movies that we see today um that's
why i said romance it really hits home
um i don't real yeah i don't know i mean
i guess this is
you know x-men as well but you know what
you get to discover
you know and in the new mutant story is
really there was a point in the movie
when i was watching it
where it kind of touched like you know
there was that 14 year old kid in me
where i was like oh these are just kids
just trying their
best they didn't feel like superiors it
was like it was a very there's a very
break that i felt it was like
i was like they were really brave for
what they were doing and you know
that just kind of just add on to henry
it was you know that
part of it and you guys really henry and
henry and charlie also have a bit of a
bromance in it for sure
[Laughter]
i think that's also existed in the
comics now yeah yeah i mean yeah we
touched on all those things and really
even the romance between
blue and uh maisy was developed from the
fact that they have a telepathic sort of
connection in the comic and uh
had a lot more intimacy than other
characters dead if you become part of
the mcu
um uh i guess which mcu character would
you love to have uh
scenes with i guess i would like to
wait i'm just gonna answer it i don't
know
don't worry well um i think
logically it would make sense if danny
had scenes with what
tessa thompson right about here because
danny moonstar is a valkyrie
so that would make eventually
thompson did say her character was what
um
looking for a queen yeah so um
like danny yeah
i like that blue pulled out a deep comic
pull like she went into the long box and
just pulled up
yeah i'm more excited about the thing
that the mcu hasn't explored yet i mean
i love the mcu characters but i'm really
excited to see the extension of the new
mutants if it bleeds into the
mcu narrative like you know people like
war
not people he's not person
psyche and i don't know karma karma's
one we like a lot
and you know warlock was in was it
really all the drafts we did
almost up to about three or four months
before we shot but he doubled our budget
he was so expensive so uh
that was always hopeful for the next
movie was warlock
maybe because he can turn into anything
in the universe that might
makes it makes it expensive
i actually want to do a follow-up to
that you'd mention that uh if
you were to do a sequel it would take
place in brazil um
has there been uh has there been any
talk
about since the whole disney thing um
about doing more
no i mean it's like i think everybody
needs to see what happens with this one
and see if it catches on or not but it's
like we did always have a plan to kind
of do a second movie set in brazil but
it'd be warlock and karma being
introduced and then uh
a third one that sort of utilized the
inferno crossover series from
x-men in the 90s which was one of my
favorites growing up
that i thought was in the same tonal
ballpark is doing horror stuff in each
one
each one was sort of a different sort of
horror movie the second one was going to
be an alien invasion
movie and then the third one's sort of
more like a magic
uh anya related you know inferno one
it sounds so cool um we were ambitious
in our minds
so no pressure to the fans and just
dependent
uh i i'm sorry to ask this with the cast
on but josh i do want to ask you a
little bit about editing
how long for example was your first cut
compared to the finished film
uh not that much different uh so i've
had the same editors since my first
movie they're some of my best friends i
have dinner with them every sunday night
back when we used to be able to have
dinner together but we've done that for
about a decade they're
just wrapped up cutting the stand uh so
you know i cut the basically 75
of this movie with them and then they
were cutting the stand already
when i finished it so i brought in
another editor to do the final stuff
with me so i mean
i don't know you just sit in there and
tinker but i'd say we were 75
done and then did the last percentage uh
just in the past year
got so uh how long is the movie can you
share that
oh yeah i think it's 98 minutes or
something like that it was never more
than i think 104 even at its longest you
know i think of my initial
i remember my initial cut before we cut
anything out was probably 20 minutes
longer than that but uh
you'll see all that on the special
features we put together all the deleted
scenes for everybody
it was more just like stuff that was
either too funny or like uh
tonally just didn't quite go together
but it's cute character moments that i
think fans will like
i cannot wait to see it um for for
everyone
um because i'm basically out of time or
almost out of time
i would love it if uh each of you could
share maybe like a fun memory
or something cool that happened while
you guys were filming just
you know what i mean like what do you
remember most from making new mutants
you're asking us to go deep back into
the memory bank
this was we were we were all younger
then
i mean i i don't know if we're allowed
to say so much about the set parts but
uh to me was really exciting that we
were in the middle of nowhere and it was
just mainly
six actors [ __ ] in the same hallway in
this
hotel and we got really close and you
know
every other night we'd hang out together
and drink boxed wine and
like some sort of fraternity camaraderie
um special moments that you know only
movie sets can give you
yeah yeah i think yeah discovering kind
of character
relationships and then have you know
friendship relationships in our group
it was was you know one of the
highlights of doing this
uh and yeah
i mean we also just had a real you know
we had a really great team
um you know from our dp to our first
idea it was a really
i think when you step onto these films
there's always like a fear of
kind of that so how big it is and
getting kind of like not lost in that
but being a feeling like a little cog in
a big machine
and uh it really didn't with this it
felt
you know like a really contained film
set and that
kind of reflects in the film so for the
experience of making it
you know was just such a really pleasant
one for me i guess and how it was
crafted together
felt very kind of you know joined
together i guess the thing i'd say is uh
i got to make this with my best friend
who i've known since the day i was born
our moms are best friends and we kind of
grew up reading marvel comics together
so i'd say aside from
getting to spend time with this cast who
was like the best cast i ever could have
asked for uh
getting to go make this with him and
have him be there uh was really
fun and it was like a childhood dream
come true um
i think it's funny because i think per
what josh
charlie and and henry said it was a very
special film because even though it's
like it's an
x-men world movie like it's a new
mutants movie and it in
the heart like the mind of everybody
it's like this gigantic set and all that
which in moments it was but the crew i
think because how
josh is as a person and as a director as
a
as an artist it felt very much
like like an indie movie in that sense
that everybody
was connected he has a very strong
relationship with his partners you know
creative partners the dp the the the
the art how do you guys say our director
it's not our directors the
the set designer production designer is
art directors how to say portuguese
sorry
but saying all of that i think it comes
a lot from josh and i think his choice
of putting us
into that place that we filmed which was
a so real
it wasn't a build set it was an actual
location i think you brought that sense
of
of you know that strength for all of us
that we were doing something real
and not just like on a digital studio
set and i think
that brought a very special vibe for us
to be together
in that location with all the actors i
mean for me that's a very
fun memory that i have like it was an
amazing experience in my life
for sure it was the first thing i ever
really did was like the first real set i
was
you know ever on i was you know um
i was 21 when i got there so yeah i mean
every day there was like kind of a new
memory i'll never forget
um i feel like you and maisie had such a
good relationship and you guys became so
close
me and maisie were pretty insane on set
some days like we
we couldn't stop laughing sometimes
she's definitely one of you know the
closest friends i'll ever have now in my
life
um she's just a great person we had so
much fun on set all of us did though
like there's a lot of scenes between
just like two people so we weren't
always
all on set together so the days that we
were
was really fun for us to all be there
um but a lot of times it was like just
me and maisie or just me and elise
me and elise did so much
that was really cool like getting to
learn
from someone like like alyssia you know
from the legend
we would always nate and i would always
look at each other and be like that's
the girl from city of god
[Laughter]
um listen i i have to rap i could ask
you guys about 75 other questions
and after i've seen the movie i will but
all i can say is thank you so much for
getting on this call with me
i cannot wait to see the finished film
thank you so much